- Right. So we're going
to do a talk about,
but I always talk
about the ups and downs of
being a gangster marker.
I'm going to give you
some downsides on it.
Sometimes that I straight lost.
It came out on, we'll say the short end
of the stick, always people always get
up here and talk about,
the things they did.
And I get up here
and talk about all the times
I have one, but there's a lot
of times that I have
lost, I've lost money.
I lost drugs.
I've lost weapons, women, what I mean?
My wife, my kids, everything,
being a gang member, there are so
many things that come
with it, what I mean?
You go to jail and your girl leaves you
and then guys sit there
and they whine over it.
I mean, that's part of being a gangster,
that's that comes with just the territory.
what you're doing?
You're, you're bound to go
to jail and you're only, she might wait.
She might not, what I mean?
I've had everything happen to me.
when I was younger
I used to want to, sell a lot of drugs.
I want us to be a big time drug dealer.
He see you guys stay on. I
want to be just like him.
So I saved up my money
and I had about maybe about six, $700.
And I went to my older homies and they
they told me, yeah, we'll
get it for you. Don't trip.
So they took me around all day
with drove me everywhere and I'm waiting
for him to get my and they never get my.
And I'm wondering why, why did he
why is he doing this to me?
And so I see him, we're
sitting at the park
and I'm asking him, Hey
man, where's my dope man.
Where's my.
I gave you the money and they're older.
So they're telling me
not, we ain't giving you.
Well, at that time, my
little brother comes from
behind it and wax the guy
in the back with the stick.
And I swore about 10 to 15
balloons fly out of his mouth.
And so when they hit the
ground, we pick them up
And I put them in my pocket and
I was pretty young at that time.
So I didn't know what was
even inside a balloon.
I was, I knew more or
less where it came from
what it was about, but I didn't
know exactly what it was.
So I went to one of my older
uncles and I'm like, look
the older homies burned,
burned me, took my money
but I got this from them,
And I thought he had came up, what I mean?
We opened one up and it was Brown sugar,
me and regular Brown sugar.
So I got all the way
done all the way around
And that was when I was younger,
my older homies, were younger.
So he used to take advantage of us.
They used to want us to sell,
some weed for them and,
pass like 20, $25 a day.
And we're making like
500, $600 for the immuno
and they used to work us
because we were younger.
And as I was growing up,
I could remember some occasions where,
I went one time to a party, what I mean?
And we went in there and
we were maybe about those
about nine of us, me.
So I figured it went pretty deep,
And we went in there,
and we're looking around
and we didn't see anybody,
anybody was dressed in the same attire,
So we kind of relaxed,
a few of us laughed.
The other ones we stayed
about four of us stayed.
And all of a sudden I started
noticing all these dudes
at the party were grouping
up and just staring.
And I was like, man, these guys
regular casual dudes,
they ain't got the pop doors and.
what I mean, type pants,
that's their, their era, slot,
I'm wondering what's going
on and they're grouping up.
They're grouping up.
All of a sudden, one of them comes
up and he straight
disrespects our neighborhood
and it says his neighborhood.
And I look at it, dude, I'm like, Whoa
Where in the did you come from?
He doesn't have baggy pants.
He doesn't even have a hairnet.
He has nothing here.
Everything is attire
is just so up to date.
But he's wearing tight pants
and a tight shirt and he
doesn't look like a gang member.
So once he says that,
I mean, it must've been
the whole party must have rushed us,
And then when they rushed
it, there was so many
of them that all I remember
is just getting I'm
on the ground and they're
kicking me, they're kicking me.
And one of my older homies
grabs me, picks me up to run.
And there was too many
of them drop me again.
They get us and they
throw us over this fence.
there's this, there's this fence.
And on the other side
of the fence is nothing
but thorn bushes, darn
bushes is cactus bushes.
with his own man had
like a garden in his backyard.
These juices threw us over in signs.
The thorn bushes, two of us,
two of my homies landed
inside the cactus Bush,
And I mean
it took us forever to get
out those cactus needles.
They had him all over their skin.
I had thorns, I got cut
from the, from the, from the
the guy on top of his wall.
He had put pieces of glass.
He put them inside the top of the wall,
so that if you jump his wall,
you're going to stab your hands.
Well, they threw us over.
So a lot of us got cut from the glass.
It was on the top of the wall.
And before they threw us
over, I couldn't remember
these dudes whispering,
and telling each other,
let's just take him for a ride.
let's take them over here.
Let's take them over there.
And we're getting stomped out.
I'm about maybe about 14 years old
the guys that are beating on me
they got to be about eight, 17, 18
because they're already
mean you ain't got mustaches
are driving their cars and everything,
and while I'm saying, part
of being a gangster is there's a downside
because those guys knew who
we were right off the top.
They knew what them looking at.
They knew what they were going to do.
And we were so unaware that
these dudes were there.
Because they just became
part of the party.
We looked at them like everybody
else, like there knowing
and then it must have
been 30 of them there,
And they whooped her.
They were every one of us.
They worked everyone on our
except two of my homies because they
they supposed to be wanting
to go get a bat or something
but they left, we got left
there and they smashed us.
after we had got smashed that weekend
we had went to, we had
went to, we wanted to go
to the carnival in hood and
we were going to go, there was
about maybe food, at least 25
to 30 of us, younger, older.
We were walking over there at work
and we're going to go smash these guys.
And as we're walking over
there, I had forgot the, the
the pipe that I had brought, what I mean?
I had forgot it when I had
used the bathroom real quick.
I set it down and I didn't
pick it up when I left.
So I'm heading back to go get my,
my stick that I had, where I was carrying.
And as soon as I picked up my
stick, I turned to the side
and I see these two dudes
coming out of an alley.
Now me and my homies,
there's like 25 of us.
So there's a lot of us like there.
So I'm thinking right off the
top, Oh, these are my homies.
So I'm already like jogging towards him.
And as I'm drugging
towards him, I'm looking at
I'm looking at, I'm
trying to recognize him.
And I'm not recognizing him
as any of my homeys that went with me.
But at that moment, this little dude, man
he pulled this big gun out of his pants.
I remember I was running towards him.
Yeah. And we pulled it out.
I just seen the Chrome.
My heart dropped.
I said, Oh.
I was already running.
So I turned, I stopped, turned around.
And I remember hearing that
this thing behind me,
I found out what kind
of gun it was, through
through people finding out.
And he was shooting a 40, 45.
And I mean, this thing was so loud
that every time he shot it,
where I could see the flash
of the muzzle and hear
the bullets just zinging
by me, I mean, cutting wins.
if you're going to hit the ground
fuel more cutting, winning.
And then I seen a couple
of my homeys fall and I
thought he had hit him.
But I guess my armies, they just got
they were ducking down.
But this young guy, man, he let
out that thing and he
shot every bullet at us,
And again, partly being against her
I go up there with my
homeys and I'm thinking
that these guys coming Allie are my homies
and little do I know
that they're my enemies
and they're coming to get us,
So they caught me by surprise.
And that occasion right there, I mean
I must've been 20 feet away from the guys
And I ran in zigzags, what I mean?
And all that good.
And I just, I'm trying
to explain the feeling
of hearing bullets as they zip by you.
Sometimes I see war movies and I
I hear the bullets in
there, zipping by the guys.
And I remember that feeling because
I've come across that
feeling so many times,
where I've been caught slipping
what I'm thinking that everything is cool.
And you don't mean these dudes
are making a plot to get me.
I went to another party up
there and it was up there and
and I used somewhere and we went up there
and I didn't know that my
homie's had moved up there
and they got in the with these dudes
but they were having
shootouts and all this.
I don't know this.
I go with another party
over, and we get there
and these dudes are deep
and these guys are deep.
They're from Fantana,
and they're deep man.
And I got my CR had on,
And they already asked me where I was
from and I told him,
And I noticed that they
started tripping on me.
I was wondering why, why
are they tripping on me?
We were all the way over
there in the inland empire.
Mine was in Los Angeles.
Why are these guys tripping?
what my own need to say
until midway through the.
Then she tells me all the homies being
in shootouts with Dame,
And I'm like, what?
You didn't tell me.
Look at these dudes.
Now these foods
these foods had already
buried, barricaded the door.
They had already blocked
the door to leave the site.
Gates blocked the door
and the house was blocked.
They blocked all exits.
And I was thinking, man,
what am I going to do?
I didn't have a chance to see anything
because as soon as I was trying to figure
out what to do, bottles
just started to come.
Bottles were just flying.
One, hit my homegirl right in
the head, smacked her right
in the head and split
her, open another one.
He hit my ankle, he hit my knee.
He hit my side.
They must, they were throwing,
food bottles of beer.
They were throwing that at us.
And we weren't that far with it.
Maybe like 15 to 20 feet,
And again, I I'm dressed in the attire
I'm out there low riding,
being a cholo gang banging
but I really didn't understand
that what I was was like a poster.
I was like a bulletin board.
I was putting myself there as a target.
Other guys were a little
smarter, what I mean?
My home is used to wear pink snapshots
and Bermuda shorts, and
catch dudes slipping.
I used to see my homie and
I used to laugh and I'm like
look at this dude,
But he never went to jail.
He never got caught.
He never got sweated by the police.
But me being, getting stirred
up when sites 50 went
on, they were like at 36
what I mean, fifties, big old sweater
a hairnet and all, what I mean?
A beanie on cholo down,
I was getting caught slipping because,
I dressed the attire that my uncles had.
I wanted to follow in their footsteps.
And every day for
I could say maybe eight
years I dressed nothing
but a gang member, in January, everything
I could have been Dan at jerseys.
And that went on for eight years.
And there was so many occasions
where I went somewhere
and I didn't recognize these guys
but they recognized me just
from what I was wearing.
They knew who I was, they had, they
they had asked why I was in
I didn't ask who they were because they
didn't have the attire on, what I mean?
They, they, they were dressed
in a different fashion.
Well, that those were,
those are these guys.
Now you got these other guys
on the other side that, they don't
they didn't actually form a neighborhood
but they got with your neighborhood.
Him and maybe six of his
boys got jumped by my homeys.
And now I'm over here
at a pool party and I'm
kicking back with some women.
And these dudes are giving me looks
and I don't know who these guys
I don't see no tattoos on him.
I see nothing but little by little
my homegirls starts whispering to me
about these dudes getting
in with my homeys.
So now I know I'm asking, well
all I could do is went in the
bathroom and they're pounding
on the door and there's a little window.
I mean, the bathroom window is so small
that I don't think I could get out of it.
I don't think I can get
out of it. It's too small.
But I said, man, I'm not going
to be well back out that door
with these dudes vendor,
there's too many of them,
they want to me up or
they're liable to kill me.
So I got to get out there window.
So I tried to get out the window
and my sweater didn't want
to get, it was too big.
I had a big sweater
and it didn't want to get there through.
So I took my sweater off.
what I mean
throughout the window now
I'm squeezing through.
And then my pants get stuck.
Well, my belt
because I used to pool in the first bucket
but the second buckle back
I used to, well, he didn't.
So the crease was right here.
It was getting stuck on the,
on the lock of the window wall.
By this time they're already
already chipping from
them, kicking in the door.
It's a nice door, nice bathroom door.
I had already put the cabinet against it.
A trash Gagnon.
I said some up against it
so that I could get time
to get out this window.
Well, I'm about out this window
and I feel that grabbed my pant leg.
And then when he grabbed my
pant leg, I fell out the window
but he didn't let go on my pant leg.
So now I'm hanging upside down.
I'm calling from my hunger.
She done ran, left me.
Now. Now I'm hanging out
the back of this window.
This, you got me by the pants and I can't.
I can't get, try to grab his hand.
I can't do nothing, but I feel
his grip loosening is good
loose steam loose anymore.
So I'm trying to wiggle away
from him and I can hear him inside there.
I could hear him running
around through the living room
trying to come out the front door.
So they get me on the side of the house.
Well, what happened was he finally let go.
I hit the ground.
I got up.
And what I did was right.
There was a Bush
a big green Bush, just
a big, big green Bush
maybe about six feet wide,
maybe about 11 feet tall.
It was just a big.
Bush looked like a Christmas tree around.
Well, all I did was I
stepped right inside it.
What I did was I went all the way
inside it to the middle of the trucks.
And I got all inside that Bush.
And I swear, these Jews were walking.
Like I could see their faces,
cause I'm holding my breath.
Only one.
Hear me breathe.
what I mean
inside this Bush right in
the middle of the tree.
And they're just walking by,
I don't know what made
me go inside that Bush
I guess it was out of
I wanted to hide so bad because
there was nowhere to hide
and that was the best place to hide.
After that, I hit there
all kinds of times.
If I found the biggest 3D man, I seen it.
I'm high there.
One day, I'm running, I'm
going to go inside there.
what that I learned to hide
in bushes and trees to
get away from people
behind me is Jude's catching
me in a bathroom, me jumping
out of the bathroom window
and I got to jump in a Bush.
And sometimes when you
jumping in that Bush
it's not clean inside there.
it's real dirty in there.
Ain't got that dude.
I mean, cobwebs leap, what I mean?
Got all kinds of bugs.
you come out of that dirty as hell,
but yet it saved my life.
But on another hand me mean a gang member
or wanting to wear the
big clothes wants to,
not play the part, but be the part.
It caused a lot of
attention, not only attention
from individuals, but also
attention from the law.
the law, they would see me
and they would pull me
over every chance they gun.
And because my homie knocked
out two new ones, sheriffs
we used to have the Sheriff's
com you put us on the hood
and then they would
give us what you used to
call a pineapple.
he put his hands
like this and it hit us
right between the lines
amazing sentence on top of the hood,
he's doing that for like about, Oh.
He must have been doing that
for about a good five months.
He was doing that to us.
He pineapples and it hit us
between the legs and nothing on the car.
And then my homeys that used,
he would get their syringe
and he would poke their
arms, with the syringe
you just poke them a lot.
And that was just because we're standing
on the corner or address the attire,
because everybody else
wasn't getting pulled over.
these dudes would
these cops would recognize
this from a block away.
Because like I said, at that time
I didn't figure that I
was a Buddhist in board.
I was assigned Saint,
look at me, look at me
come and get me, where are we going to do?
I was
I was portraying a role
that was embedded in me.
It was breaded to me.
I didn't choose.
I can't say I didn't choose.
I, I, more or less got led
into being a gang member.
It wasn't my choice.
I didn't grow up and say, okay
well I can either be a gang member
or I can stay at school and
be a, no, it wasn't like that.
Once I had 12, 13 years
old, it was one steady road.
And that was the role
that they pushed my family
and my cousins and my uncles.
They pushed that.
So,
I didn't get the opportunity
to be maybe who I wanted to be.
I already knew by the age of 13
that this is what I was
going to do this as well.
I was going to go, prison and everything.
And that was going to happen.
It was never trouble.
It was all going to take place.
I was going to go to
prison for a long time.
And that's exactly what
happened, what I mean?
I wish now today I knew
the things that I don't
I wish I would've known
them then because then
I would have been a
lot, a lot more clever,
a lot more smarter, what I mean?
And not so flamboyant with it,
mean flamboyant with it.
what I'm talking about?
I used to be the type of individual that
I wouldn't disrespect you
in front of your mother
or your wife, or, your kids,
I wouldn't disrespect you in front of them
but there was a lot of
individuals that did
And I hated that.
I really hate
that because the fact that, someone
with their mother or
their old lady, I feel
that they get a chance,
when you let them walk by
they got a freebie, some
guys wouldn't allow that.
Some guys wouldn't go
for that with your
mother, with your ladies
they're going to try to shoot
you and put you in the ground.
They just don't care.
But what was I doing?
I was out there all
dressed, gangbanger down
putting a sign up, shoot me, what I mean?
And it, it, it today, what I mean?
I even put on pants that
are a little bit snug
and I feel that they're too tight.
Even if they're not too tight or my size
I still feel like they're tight.
I try to give up, the
big shirts or the ones
with LA on them, the
attire that is been so hard
for me to give up little by
little, I'm cutting it out
in my life, but being as
a gang member, a cholo
it's embedded in my head
that when I hit a store
there's one section I'm going
to look at, that's the section
with the long socks, the
black shirts, the Levi's,
I'm not going and looking
at shorts with flowers
on them, Hawaiian shorts
or Hawaiian shirts.
I don't think I've ever
owned a Hawaiian shirt
or Hawaiian shorts.
I never owned nothing like that.
And even though the suit, I've wore a suit
but I've never owned one myself.
I never had a suit
or a coat to wear out to somewhere.
Nice. what I mean?
I always had to either
buy it or borrow it,
because I couldn't wear
the clothes that I usually
wear to someone's wedding.
I mean, come on.
That's where the place, what I mean?
So, I share these things
because everybody talks
about the good side of
being a gang member.
the good side
of being a gangster of being a drug dealer
but they never hit the
points about the bad things.
They never show people
that there's one sort
of bad side to this.
There's also a side that no one sees
and no one talks about
because it's forbidden.
But yet, I bring it out today and I talk
about things that happened in
my life because I was so naive
to the fact that I put a sign on my back.
24 seven.
I asked the wonder
how did these know where I was at?
How did they know who I was?
Why did they shoot at me?
I should have known
exactly why I was dressed
like a gang member.
I was standing in front of an
unknown gang members house.
And I was throwing up gang signs.
So, as I got older
I came to realize that
there's a very bad side
of being a gangster and
there's a good side.
And you hear a lot of people
talk about the good side
but very few talk about the bad things.
They don't want to tell you
that they came to downtown
and they gave somebody $60 and
they gave him six balloons.
And one of them was only real.
The other five were fake
and brought that burner was this little
She's just a little brother
and she straight burner
they won't tell you that, but I will.
I tell you, I came to downtown.
I got burned by the smallest, bro.
You think?
And I gave him my money.
Like he was nothing and I knew better.
And she came back and gave me my.
And it was one of the one that was real.
All the rest were fake and I was.
I was upset, but she got me,
she got me and she played the game.
She was wiser as quicker.
Right. And she took my money.
The thing that happened
to me was I had my weapon.
I loved my weapon.
I had my app and wherever
I went, I slept with it.
It went everywhere.
I went and I went
to this girl's house and
started being with her.
And I up.
She told me, Oh man
this guy's sweating and he's
coming over and stalking me.
I need something.
So me like a dummy, I go
and grab my weapon and
bring it to her house.
Thinking that everything's okay.
That was the wrong thing to do.
But me being
I want to be captain save a
whole, no disrespect to anyone
but I only to captain save
a whole and say this brought
from her problems by
bringing my heat over there
and little do I know she has a she's
with on the side, waiting
for him to come to get my.
So I ain't like come
back a little spot where
I have my and it's gone.
She told the other dudes
that no, I can't get it.
This guy and telling me, give me my.
He asked my.
He he's going to shoot me if I ask for my.
So now I'm stuck in a predicament.
What? Because I was
walking down the street
this see me
call me because how I
was dressing, everything
hit me up where I was from and everything.
Then she explained her problems.
And me being a naive idiot
when he got my weapon
brought it, she gave it to the other dude
told him it was at, he got, it burned me
for a thousand dollar
weapon and it was gone,
And I'll be the first one to
say, right? I shed a tear.
It hurt bad. I didn't
want to lose that thing.
And when I lost it, I shed a tear
because it meant so much to
me, it was like a part of me.
And when I lost it, I felt naked.
I felt like I was here there.
And why?
Because I listened to
a woman that played me
all the way through, all that.
She was scared of him.
That was just an act.
She was giving me that way.
She could get my weapon
and give it to her man, whoever it was
you and I never seen this dude again, I
I wanted to hope and pray
that they see me getting by.
I never seen him again, but
he got me from my weapon.
And that was because
again, my attire, she me
because the way I wore my clothes and
I grew up I'm on clothes so much because
even the Raiders jerseys,
the Raiders sweaters
they ain't even labeled
them as gang attire.
And that's a team, that's the NFL team
but it was getting a tire. we
can even wear that to school.
we couldn't wear nothing Raiders to school
nothing black, nothing, no
colors, gang member colors.
Now I don't know.
Gang member colors.
All I know is they're black, silver, what
what do you mean?
We couldn't wear certain things to school.
And it was like why their
sports, but we couldn't wear them
because the media and society
labeled that as gang attire.
So we were not allowed to wear it
to the probation office to school.
So things had to change.
We had to make changes and I
started wearing white t-shirts
and like that, but
still, it didn't matter.
I thought if I changed my entire little
they won't recognize me.
Cause if they didn't recognize me
by my clothes, they recognized me.
By the way I walk, what I'm
for some reason people
say I walk a certain way.
I'm not too keen on how I walk
but people have recognized me how I walk
and they knew it was me.
And it's like, you
recognize me for my walk.
I must walk there from
there. A lot of people.
But I used to get caught
slipping behind that too.
telling me later on the years
all I knew was you
because I seen you walking
down the street and I was like
you see me walking down the street?
Why'd you get me that it was
the scene from a distance
but I recognize you're walking.
I was like, what the?
He recognized me walking.
He came and shot at me.
Cause he recognized it was me.
Well, what I mean?
There there's so many things that,
we don't look at, what I mean?
We thought big, our head would look cool.
Vicky and her aunt just put a sign on her
back for the cops, his gang member.
He's bald head, go get him.
I grew up with long hair.
Call me my hair back with a
Palm Palm and the hair in it.
After I went into shaving my head.
But I didn't really care
for shaving my head.
So, but when that came in
everybody shaving their
head and there we go again
putting a bulletin board on her back,
that sign saying, come and get me
look at me and look who I am.
So,
I wanted to share a little
bit today about that.
There's the good and the bad
of being a G and you people
know that are gangsters, man
that I come up here and
talk about the real.
There is a bad side and a
good side to everything.
maybe when you, when you guys get up here
you can share some as well,
some bad things that happened
because people read it all
the time and they hear a lot
of good about everybody coming on top.
Looping it to tell them
about when you came out
on the bottom, because they
also want to hear about that.
You, you get tired of hearing the same.
Cause you just get to him.
He never loses.
Yeah, loses.
But what I learned is as long
as my losses overcome, as long as my
my victories overcome my losses,
then I'm doing all right.
If I got more losses than
victory, I would do bad.
But I think I got more victory.
So you don't want to share
that today with you, Mark.
- You tell me about, tell me
about the scar on your face.
Oh, you have a scar going
from your eye down your cheek.
- My face, if that was done
by one of my best friends
today, my best friend,
I'm a strong believer in you
get disciplined on the 11th
- Katie herself on.
So when I up
- There's no checking verbal checking.
There's no verbal tongue lashing.
There's no whooping.
they ain't going to kick me on the ground.
No, my thing is I just stabbed shot.
I got to get punished severity because
I'm going to punish severely
whatever level you're on.
And I have to punish you.
I'm going to punish you on that level.
You carry yourself on.
I'm not going to put you anywhere else.
Just on that level.
You're curious off mine and my homie
he jumped the gun kind of with theirs.
And at the same time he took
in somebody else's information
and just took it in.
But then again,
today's my best friend
because I can sit here
and honestly say that I don't hate him.
I don't hold nothing against him
because the fact that he
corrected me when I was wrong
it could have been worse,
But today I see him and
I had my chance to talk to the man and
I let him know, you touch me again.
You're no more, but
at the same time he did it to
discipline me and I was wrong.
I was wrong.
I understand where I was wrong.
I seen where I was wrong
and I accepted it like a man, even though
in some of my face, women,
other scars, man, they dig them.
it's just another story to tell,
people think, man, how come
you didn't end this guy?
Because the fact
that he did what most won't do
He stepped to the plate and
took care of his business.
And when most won't do that
they won't correct me.
They let me hit a wall instead
of correcting me right there on the spot.
And my correction has
to be severe to get it.
Let me hit that wall where
correction is no longer valid.
It's no longer a choice.
you're a beyond correction.
Now you have to be ejected,
And I'd rather be corrected that injected.
I'd rather be handled then
could be stuck in question.
Cause to being questioned
it's very uncomfortable to just sit there
and not know if you're asked out
or you're okay to sit
there and not know it.
And you can't go nowhere,
but they're just waiting
on the word to come back on you.
It's up.
So again, there's something like faith
my best friend today, he put this
on my face and I don't
even see it anymore.
Just like my tear drop.
I don't see it.
When I look in the mirror,
I don't see the teardrop.
I don't see the scar.
I don't see nothing.
I just see my face.
I don't, I don't see it.
It's not there.
But a lot of people ask
about it and my life is an open book.
So I can share it with anybody.
I've been asked
about my teardrop or so many times
but the best one I ever
gave was a CEO in prison.
She was sexy as hell.
She called me to her podium.
She says, excuse me, I'm Ramirez.
And I said, yes.
She said, I want to ask you a question
but I don't want you to take it personal
but I've been wanting to ask you and I go
go ahead and ask it.
She said that teardrop on your face.
Does that mean that
you're missing somebody?
And I sit, no, I sit, no man.
That means that somebody
else is missing somebody.
And she looked at me
like, Whoa, what the hell?
But she asked the question.
I gave her the answer.
She had to respect it.
She said, well, somebody's
missing somebody.
I said, no, somebody else
was missing somebody.
I wasn't missing nobody.
So I gave her her answer
and she took it like,
Whoa, this is my wall.
My God.
How could you, you asked me the question.
I'm going to give you the answer.
You don't.
My church has faced since
the age of 15 as it was when
where I went to prison by
then. And I did a year by man.
No, no.
it's filled
in it's dark and everybody
knows what that means.
So, I went on both
on faith and I learned with pride
because there are things
that I have earned both ways
the good way and bad way.
Let's say the battle in the good way
both because they're back and forth
one's good, one's bad.
And I always said it was a good
side and there's a bad side
to me, the gangster, here's the good side.
Here's the bad side.
Because fact that I had
to do bad to get this
and I had to do good to get
this, But when you look at them
and some of these they're both bad things
but at the same time,
what does that story?
What does that scarred hold?
What type of story does it hold?
Cause I wasn't cut because I
told them somebody I wasn't cut
because I said the wrong thing.
No, I was cut because
I did something wrong
and the men chose to take him
to his hands and correct
me before I went too far
and was unable to be corrected anymore.
So I wear with pride minute and it's cool.
women love it.
They always want to kiss it.
I'm not lying.
I mean they do, especially white Rosie.
They love her man.
they live with your dropping in scars.
Why? I do not know, but
Mike was just loving it.
So I dig a man and they're cool.
It's cool.
but again
my best friend did it
and that's my boy, man.
I love him more than I
love a lot of other people.
So that's where it came from.
Mark. Is that cool?
Excellent. Alright Mark.
Thank you man.
No problem, Mark.
I got some more for you, man.
I got you only do more. I'm
going to write something down.
I'm going to write some down
because like I be talking
to my homie and he be telling
me, man, you remember this?